Goom resumes Paris hi welcome back to me
most of you bros probably haven't
noticed because there's still been
videos but I've been away for a holiday
for a week and I'm back and walking dead
season 2 finale is here we're gonna play
it I am so freaking excited I know a
couple of my friends have played it
already and they said it was amazing and
everything you ever wanted
so let's do this but before we begin
I've been told you're supposed to watch
the trailer first because it contains
some stuff to get you in the right mood
so I thought why not do that together I
want you both to be in the right mood
you always are in my videos I'll stop it
all right here we go
rated M for Mature all my videos should
start like that it's a 5 minute trailer
early shed
[Music]
if you really want to skip this i'll
leave an annotation but I think we
should wash it anyway I remember that
that [ __ ] they told us there's a scene
that we haven't seen before in the
trailer so what happened to your parents
if you don't mind me asking parents went
on vacation and loved me with a
babysitter
I remember that room we went to Savannah
to find them
but they were already dead
this man found me and took care of me we
met up with other survivors and we all
tried to make
it didn't work
[Music]
of duck
Oh goddamn it he taught me how to
survive he taught me how to shoot a gun
[Music]
I'm doing
the same thing that happens to everyone
I can't watch that part without getting
teary acts
[Music]
it was a dog
right now
[Music]
hell yeah yeah eating cereals like it's
nobody's business
listen everyone just stay calm
Sarah get be nice and tell us who you
are
hey you know a half expected to see
League walk up next
[Music]
ah
some of these folks ain't too keen on
something else to figure out a way out
of here
just not care where
[Music]
oh it could have ended like that that
was way cooler
I did that note
[Applause]
I did that too
[Music]
yeah it ended with such a cliffhanger oh
my god what's what's the say we are
strong it's why it falls to people like
us like you lemme clue what what if this
oh sorry there's something in the tree
house and she wants me to get a video of
it to show you guys the door peeking out
Clemmy I sake ah it's rock
it's the dreamy sadder
[Music]
I have rabies I'm here mom I love you
too I miss you don't worry sweetie okay
see you soon
adorable
gives you some contrast well here we can
hashtag my claiming game hi shag my
climbing clue excuse me
all right well let's fire this bad boy
up all right here we are chapter 5 if
you know the mentor it's always kind of
sad just knowing that this is the end
but I'm very very very excited and
that's how it ended how the hell are we
gonna someone must have died
someone must have died with that this
game series of absurd shows you make the
stories tale about how you play we know
this by now do you really need to tell
us that others are good to be around
every once in a while here we are still
shooting I want to see what's going on
please I heard Clemmy I hope she hasn't
been shot or anything
Oh
who's died oh my god what am i doing
oh my craft are we gonna up wait we are
doing it I repeat we are crawling for
say baby ah Jesus calm your tits we
shoot a little girl crawling to save a
baby
what the [ __ ] well I'm picking a baby I
went through so much [ __ ] effort for
this baby I'm not gonna let it go now
Oh geesh okay okay we got to do
something
it starts off so intense what are we
supposed to do then oh well that's nice
of him to translate okay I'm holding a
baby bang bang
I miss oh no oh oh oh nice going kini
went straight through
okay what is Kenny doing Oh Kenny don't
do that yeah that's not helping anyone
okay I'll do something hey guy you're
welcome
but she was dead anyway Oh oh Jesus this
is awkward
what the [ __ ] oh hi
my statue before I die
Jesus well that went a lot better than
expected
I got him how is everyone alive
how the hell did we do that doesn't even
look at us
Jesus Christ that was I was intense wait
he can walk man I thought that was it it
was for these [ __ ]
thanks for coming back I didn't know
this man
I never killed someone that didn't
wronged me in some way that didn't
deserve it
tried to pretend he was a walker but
it's different I didn't think it would
be you saved us
yeah that's why I did it but I felt
wrong yeah we kind of felt like the bad
guys here honestly yeah she doesn't
happen to say I sort of wish that was
true
let's go so she is staying oh oh
never get to reflect on it
she didn't really get to be a mother to
that long
how did this happen she turned just like
that don't you go blaming yourself Kenny
you did what you had to
to protect the boy she just lost too
much blood ain't nobody's fault
you know we could have done better by
her she was just too far gone
she's with Alvin now yeah yeah she's
don't worry Becca I'll take care of your
boy last easy [ __ ] oh hey hey I feel
like he deserves it how can you say that
of course he is
get out of the way whoa what are you
doing I'm doing the same thing this
[ __ ] tried to do to us it doesn't
have to go down like that he wasn't the
one shooting at us that guy's dead
just cuz he don't have a gun doesn't
mean he wouldn't have well he didn't so
leave him alone
this house food please please I can
thank you [ __ ]
really we have please not for food see
he wants to help
oh don't be stupid he's just trying to
save his skin why the hell would you
help us yeah good point people did and
close your eyes and I'll make it quick
oh if he's telling the truth it could
save all of us
we need the food none of this will
matter if we all starve to death
she's right Kenny we're running low on
supplies as it is it's worth the risk to
check this place out trust him don't
trust him it doesn't matter everyone is
against candy Jesus need to be careful
it can't be far from here you stay out
of this
you're the reason these [ __ ] came
after us in the first place don't try
and pin this on me
lay off Kenny she just helped us I was
there with her it's my fault to think
about the baby Kenny bear supplies we
need we ain't gonna last much longer
without more food we gotta take a chance
unless someone's got a better plan
take a chance ten second chance has yeah
Kenny yeah I thought she made the baby I
don't know why thank you
just give me a reason yeah man he gets
it so are all of them dead are all the
Russians dead
five were Russian I would be so offended
right now like they must have shot worse
in song tripperz seriously we're
literally right next to each other when
the gun went off when I heard the
gunshots I I knew it was a mistake
I'm not good I didn't despite what my
instincts are telling me despite
everything I've seen everything I've
been through I'm not pissed I'm glad
you're back I didn't want you to go in
the first place I'm not pissed Thanks
good for you that's good good because
you're probably 90% of the reason I came
back and then probably get pretty
annoying if you hated me the whole time
wouldn't want it to be annoying no I
would suck I'm gonna try to make this
work
I'm surprised Lucas okay promise you I
won't which to be fair I've never done
before even though I probably should
have a few times now you know gotta
point the gun at him the whole time
you forget what we just went through you
ain't going anywhere Kenny no need to
get your arm also I'm worried about
Kenny he's he's in a dark place we got
to keep an eye on get it keep an eye
everything he's been through he's lost
it's changing him so this is you making
it work you don't have to constantly be
criticizing him nah I just want to side
with kami sometimes I feel like there's
gonna be a decision one day trust that
he really trusts that means you were the
one that's gonna have to pull him back
Oh God hang on you if we're really going
to make this work we're all counting on
you I'll do my best I know
[Music]
come on hop out what did you just call
me it's gonna be a decision between
Kenny and Luke I feel like Ken is always
so unreasonable and so only so annoying
and he always does his [ __ ] that's so
out of line but we have history man yeah
history god damn it
and we know what Kenny's been through we
know why he's like that so it's kind of
hard to not even though he's acting
crazy it's kind of hard not to not like
him it's pretty unlikable me if you
think about no no I'm fine I just need a
second sorry I just split more weight on
it than I should all right wait there
hey what'd I say tell you something
listen you understand Kenny come on
there's no need for that I was getting
what he deserves he did saw his sister
mane
[ __ ] talking to you that's enough
leave him alone just [ __ ] stay put
it's what is he
Kenny I'm gonna have a word with Kenny
he doesn't have to treat him that way
kids been through enough
you all right here yeah yeah go on and
talk to him I got clam if I need
anything okay here just take the baby
okay
what is it with you guys what do you
mean every man I've known is always
trying to let each other know how tough
they are
put him in their place bunch of dominant
alpha male horseshit and it all ends the
same way I don't look at me I hate that
guy
oh that ain't true you get in your fair
share of pissin matches down zoom I mean
are you kidding me yes
guess I should work on that they're not
all like that there are good men too my
friend Lee he was a good man
well I wish I had had a chance to meet
him me too
I wish she was here now me too yes it
took a woman to talk some sense into him
looks like Jane broke it up keep
pressure on it okay I'm gonna go fetch
some bandages like how come you how the
hell can you walk a knight diocese hey
Bonnie
yeah I'm sorry for what for your face
I'll be right back sorry how are you
feeling I'm being honest I've been
better
well no [ __ ]
what's going on here what is this what I
get here
what do you mean sitting in the snow
leaning up against a tree bullet in male
but alive when so many of my friends
aren't dead no good reason and I
couldn't do anything stuff
every one we set out with just gone me
Pete Alvin and Becca
Carlos Sarah and for what you can't
blame yourself
it wasn't your fault no completely I
could have done more and that ain't up
for debate I know what my bones I guess
that's true mr. mark that's perfect
what a mess
hmm nothing much you know mostly I was
just mentioning how cold it is lately
yeah good thing you got that cool jacket
oh god stop it for the damn jacket I'm
sure most of that'll come out with a
little soap and water Thanks most of it
hey clam go over and see if you can
change the bandages on Kimmy's wound I
offered but I don't think he was
comfortable with me doing it but you
know him better than I do maybe he'll
let you do it
I don't know if they'll let me you may
not but you oughta try that's gonna
sting but only for a second it's gonna
clean it oh I know what it does it's
gonna suck it's gotta get done that
hurts so [ __ ] much I remember I was a
kid that got that on my I got to put
that on my leg and he's like I can't
imagine what its gonna be in the eye I
was thinking we go with Alvin jr. what
do you think he misses Rebecca mentioned
she'd like to name him Alvin if it was a
boy I mean Rebecca was so out of it she
hadn't settled on her name I think his
parents would have liked that yeah me
too
I can't yeah because in jr. it is do you
like that well I think AJ approves what
do you got there cuz I think I'm alright
I mentioned it earlier to Bonnie I'm
changing your bandage sounds like I
don't have much choice in the matter
there we go you don't
have to do stuff like this shouldn't
have to do a lot of things alright let's
get it over with hopefully don't scare
this little guy I don't want to see this
Oh God all right poker face
it's okay I trust you
pokerface pokerface I'm still gonna be
pretty when this heals
well looks a lot better than it did and
maybe my modeling days ain't over trust
me they ain't you looking fab they say I
thought it would be more disgusting to
be honest why what happened
I my mouse is going outside my screens I
can't really there we go
so
I'm guessing this is gonna be the shitty
part
what's doing so this is gonna hurt like
hell
well you coulda lied a little you know
yeah that's gonna hurt like hell Oh God
you would stop swarming you should not
be holding the baby okay that's for sure
right oh sorry about the language Junior
don't be tougher than me when you're
grown I'm gonna expect you to be more of
a gentleman than I am
man is that smart it'll be tough just
like his dad boy Alvin didn't look it
but yeah bad guy had a pair I should
have gave myself up Alvin didn't have to
die like that I'm gonna think about that
every time I look at Alvin jr. here
elfin should be here raising this boy it
should be him the best thing you can do
for Alvin and Rebecca is raise them
right I like how it clemency
says all these adult stuff how old is
she actually it's more mature than any
of these people in the gang but I wasn't
too bad yeah are you ready to go yep
Candy's got a breastfeeding first let's
head out
how are they gonna keep the baby
nutrition what is the plan here
I write pants this is Pierce from the
future I'm sorry but I have to end this
episode here hope you enjoyed this
episode this finale is the most amazing
thing ever you bros are gonna love it
thank you for liking this video it
really helps me out a lot and it
supports me and make me feel like so
thank you for doing that
thanks for hanging out with me today
bros ad show always stay awesome